let's take it from California to New
York because AOC was given a speech and
she's up for re-election right now she
actually has a contested election and
who knows maybe she won't be in our hair
much longer she is being protested at a
lot of her events lately and she seems
to be having some sort of nervous
breakdown
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so people are very frustrated with AOC I
think her own constituents are like wait
a minute wait a minute you know you were
supposed to help us here in this
District but you've been for all of
these big spending bills our economy is
not doing so great let's say across the
country but right here at home you're
into all of this woke stuff the woman
who was yelling there was in essence
saying hey there's only two genders male
and female AOC obviously is not all
about that
um and people are not happy that she's
been voting for all this money for
Ukraine and to escalate the war and the
rest of it and it's like she just kind
of sits there and she's mocking these
people and the rest of it and it's like
you know lady you have not felt any
adversity in your life I I am really
willing to put that out there any real
adversity she pretends she's a victim
right she's a progressive so you have to
be a victim but she has not faced any
adversity and certainly no adversity
when it comes to defending her ideas
right the mainstream media absolutely
loves her she goes on CNN and you know
they they basically hand her candy and
just let her do her thing uh that's in
essence what they do everywhere she gets
on the cover of Mademoiselle and
Cosmopolitan and everything else if you
are a republican that's new to the
Congress that might be thought of as
kind of cool and new and fun they treat
you a little bit differently much like
Myra Flores the Republican who won the
Democrat seat for 100 years in the
Border Town in Texas and the New York
Times basically said she was the leader
of the new Latina or latinx far right
that's what's going on over there so
when people come and protest her now by
the way I am not for protesters
interrupting speeches I have been
interrupted a gajillion times there's
many videos of it if you haven't seen
the video that I think it's got millions
and millions of views on YouTube Google
Dave Rubin University of New Hampshire
and watch these crazy lunatic students
coordinate screaming at me and all of
this stuff and bringing noise makers and
everything else I'm not for that I I
like peaceful protest you respect the
speaker hopefully the speaker will
respect you it's why it every event that
I do I let people who disagree with me
come up first but putting putting aside
the sort of the tactics of what these
people were doing I think people have
had it and and it is AOC herself who
many times has tweeted that the point of
protest is to make people uncomfortable
get in their face right what did Maxine
Waters say get them get in their face
don't find out where they're eating
don't give them a moment's safety blah
blah blah that is what Democrat rhetoric
has done and now it's coming home the
chickens are coming home to roost lady
and uh
I think I I think there's a chance we're
not going to have much much more with
her I think she could lose this election
I think anything is possible that is how
frustrated and sick of the woke people
are